I've gathered here on this tabletop some
pieces of uh classic analog sound design
equipment today everything is digital
it's in a computer you operate it with a
mouse and a keyboard but back in the day
when Louis and BB Baron were creating
sounds for Forbidden Planet they had a a
studio that was based on magnetic tape
and at that time sounds were recorded
and played back on a roll of magnetic
tape and uh it would be threaded up in a
machine you could record sounds and wind
through it play it back you could splice
it it was a a physical medium like the
Barons did for Forbidden Planet they
started out with raw sounds so
electronic sounds they might have
sounded might have sounded something
like this well we'll demonstrate here
first we'll we'll just by playing a
sound on the original tape like
this into this machine we start
[Music]
recording put it in
playback we start bringing up the
[Music]
feedback and that original sound is now
looping around and folding itself and
unfolding itself into something brand
new sometimes harmonic sometimes
dissonant other things you can do of
course is um stop the
tape and the system becomes
self-sustaining change
speed
it's also fun just to crank the speed
through by hand at different speeds and
you can get um sounds from low frequency
to
[Music]
high
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
voila